the deployment of the planet's first
robotic police units became the focus of
the world in 2016 you're under arrest
Vincent Moore is a former soldier
problem without official intelligence is
this way too unpredictable the scouts
creator Deon Wilson sees a rich future
what interests me is a machine that can
think and feel I have a robot is
operated by thinking human being we
don't want this it's expensive it's big
and it's ugly the scouts are huge
success stop worrying about these pet
projects and I feel of cotton this is a
new kind of life on a new step in
evolution
you are choppy it's like a trial has to
learn what's it Jackie's look yeah see
all these good stories Jeff is gonna be
anything you want to do in your life you
can do write poetry have original ideas
Jimmy wasted eight wow you're able to be
problem for me a thinking robar could be
the end of mankind destroy that robot
burn it to ash
something of great danger headed our way
now
I don't want to die I want to live you
wanna survive chappie you must fight
tone as belief
you think you're real
you don't get away with this happy
special
I'm consciousness
I'm alive
I am Jeffy
you